do you see madam in this what does it
look like to me just say the first thing
that comes into your mind
hey everyone I'm a be sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen today we are celebrating
Valentine's date with my friend Julie
from feeling peckish
hi so Julie does these amazing videos
that are inspired by awesome movies so
what are we doing today we are going to
pay homage to our favorite Valentine's
Day movie which is chakra and our
favorite Valentine's Day ingredient
chocolate so we're going to be doing my
healthy banana peanut butter cups mmm
sounds delicious let's get started so
Julie we've got about 300 grams of
really good dark chocolate and Julie if
you don't mind grabbing that coconut oil
we're just going to pour that in and
we're going to melt this over a
bain-marie let it simmer over it's about
an inch of water just tell us all melts
together so this recipe here was based
on you know one of my own kind of
experiences growing up I was dating a
musician in high school but like most
musicians the guy had a total ego
he loved his hair he loved his body more
than anything he thought he was
literally the king so I thought why not
pay homage to the ultimate musical
superstar the king himself mr. Elvis bro
okay I get it I get cuz he got the
banana and a tiara so Elvis was famous
for loving that peanut butter and banana
and bacon combination he invented that
but we're not all spring chickens
anymore we can't all just be eating
bacon every single day so I want to
lighten this up by putting a little bit
of fleur de sel on top so you get that
same sweet salty combination but without
all the fat cap cool I'm excited let's
do this thing
awesome this is looking good melted you
want to grab this spoon Oh layer a
little bit onto the bottom of each of
those cups so we've got big ones and
I've also got little mini peanut butter
cups
let's pop this onto our baking tray now
let's just pop it in the freezer for
about five minutes to let it set up cool
see you later
so this is where that peanut butter
banana combination comes into room got
some ripe banana just one and we're just
going to pop it into our food processor
all this piece is going to come from
this banana so the riper the better
you've got some natural peanut butter
okay
vanilla yes I am two teaspoons of
coconut oil again okay just gonna help
to keep everything together and then we
process see how good this looks I just
want to eat this with a spoon oh you
could put on toast you told like I put
this on toast this would be the ultimate
breakfast all right so let's fill these
bad boys up you want to try not to touch
the edges because we're gonna let the
chocolate and develop that peanut butter
banana yeah so let's in develop the
whole thing in chocolate so now I mean I
don't actually have these molds at home
that's totally okay I mean you could
easily use a muffin tin with a little
muffin liner in there oh okay
or you want to do a smaller portion you
could just use an ice cube tray just
finish these last bad boys up okay so
Julie if you want to grab some that
fleur de sel and sprinkle it on top of
each other peanut butter cups
I think Elvis would totally approve of
the swap right mmm-hmm
so there you have it folks we had so
much fun celebrating Valentine's Day
with chocolate you've definitely got to
check out Julie's Channel feeling
peckish
we made a dark chocolate and rum tart
it's unreal
you're gonna love it so thanks so much
for watching guys be sure to subscribe
to my channel and I'll see you next time
on Abby's kitchen
you